winning in a great economy is easy many  people did it the last two years three  years four years heck the last since  2008  since we've had the economic expansion  the longest ever there's been a lot of  people that have made a lot of money  anybody can do that anybody can make  money in a great economy winning in any  economy is what creates true wealth the  next two years will reveal who win and  who won't so you want to make sure  you're part of the camp that's prepared  for this and you want to make sure you  have the reputation in the marketplace  to say  market crashed i made money  market was booming i made money market  was pla flat i made money i'm gonna make  money in any economy because i'm  constantly looking at ways to improve  myself by seeking strategies that are  effective in any economy